l'ordre du jour appelle la discussion
après engagement de la procédure
accélérée de la proposition de loi
visant à interdire les dispositifs
électronique électronique excusez-moi de
vapotage à usage
unique la Conférence des Présidents a
décidé que ce texte serait examiné dans
son intégralité selon la procédure de
législation en
commission en application de l'article
107-3 du
règlement nous entendrons tout d' ord
les interventions des rapporteurs de la
Commission et du gouvernement puis nous
examinerons les deux amendements déposés
afin de corriger une erreur
matériel nous entendrons ensuite les
explications de vote des groupes puis
nous passerons directement au vote de
l'ensemble la parole est donc à Monsieur
Michel lausan rapporteur de la
commission des affaires
sociales alors
excusez-moi alors par que excusez-moi ce
n'était pas dans l'ordre mais ça peut
arriver la parole est à donc Madame
Francesca pascuni rapporteur de la
commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
sociales madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales
monsieur le corrapporteur mes chers
collègues le texte que nous vous
présentons est le fruit d'un travail
initié il y a 1 an avec les associations
de lutte contre le tabac et de
protection de l'environnement cette
proposition de loi est cignée par 166
députés appartenant à H groupes
politiques différents et elle a été
adoptée à l'unanimité en commission des
affaires sociales le groupe écologiste
se félicite d'avoir été rapidement
rejoint dans ce combat par des députés
engagés comme mon collègue et
corrapporteur Michel lozana notre
objectif de ce soir est simple c'est
celui d'un interdire les peufs soit les
cigarettes électroniques jetables ou à
usage unique dont il convient d'emblé
d'indiquer qu'elles ne contiennent pas
de tabac mais peuvent contenir de la
nicotine une substance vénéneuse et à
double effet psychotrope et
addictif avant que nous en venions au
vote il me semble nécessaire d'être très
clair sur les produits visés par cette
proposition de loi l'initiative que nous
défendons aujourd'hui ne s'attaque pas
aux produits de vapotage rechargeable
qui servent souvent à sortir d'une
consommation du tabac ou aux nouvelles
formes de délivrance nicotinique je dis
cela pour que chacun dans cet hémicycle
et parmi ceux qui nous écoutent
comprennent que même si des questions
juridiques économiques ou sanitaires
peuvent se poser à propos de ces
produits nous avons fait le choix de
nous focaliser uniquement sur les peufs
pour arriver assurément et rapidement à
une pure et simple interdiction les
faricant des peuf ces objets au
développement exponentiel et anarchique
au travers d'un marketing agressif et
bien souvent illégal vise surtout à
compenser le risque pour les industriels
du tabac que les générations à venir ne
fume plus du tout apparu sur le marché
français en 2021 les PEF ont un format
compact et prêt à l'emploi beaucoup plus
pratique et discrète que les cigarettes
électroniques rechargebles ces
caractéristiques ont permis à des
commerçants aussi divers que des
magasins de décoration des kiosques à
journaux ou des grandes surfaces d'en
proposer à leurs clients les pefs sont
donc facilement accessibles et de grave
contournement de l'interdiction de vente
aux mineurs sont constatés les mineurs
en font un large usage car leur prix est
dérisoire les arômes fruités et sucrés
sont attirants la discrétion du
dispositif
les fait passer inaperçu auprès des
parents pour vous donner une idée au
Royaume-Uni leur consommation à
quadruplé sur la dernière année
actuellement h peuf finissent à la
poubelle toutes les secondes soit 5
millions chaque semaine en France 15 %
des adolescents les ont déjà utilisé et
la moitié des jeunes qui ont essayé ces
dispositifs à usage unique ou jetable
ont découvert la nicotine à travers ces
produits avec ces peufs nous avons
également affaire à une véritable
abération sur le plan
environnemental le plastique et le
lithium qui les composent ont un mode de
production très consommateur de pétrole
et d'eau extrait à l'autre bout du monde
dans des conditions déplorables les
mêmes matériaux sont aussi polluants à
la fin de leur cycle de vie car ils ne
disparaissent jamais de notre
environnement les vendeurs de produits
de vapotage nous ont indiqué que le
respect de l'obligation légale de
reprise des déchets électroniques et
électroménagés auxquels appartiennent
les peufs est presque nul les
écoorganism eux aussi reconnaissent
d'être démunis en effet même une fois
épuisés les peufs sont encore doté d'une
charge d'ion dans leur batterie et sont
donc extrêmement inflammables
facilité d'usage disponibilité du
produit publicité déguis déguisée cycle
de vie très court avec ces cigarettes
électroniques jeta tous les éléments
sont réunis pour qu'un scandale
sanitaire et environnemental voit le
jour l'interdiction totale des peuf que
nous vous proposons est donc une mesure
de santé à double titre il s'agit de
protéger la santé de nos concitoyens
mais également de protéger
l'environnement qui nous entoure la
santé des personnes n'est pas
indépendante de la santé des écosystèmes
nous devons donc agir face à ces
aberrations sanitaires et
environnementales chers collègues
l'interdiction des peufs est une étape
nécessaire pour protéger la santé de nos
concitoyens les débats en commission ont
montré que la représentation nationale
était toute entière mobilisée face au
nouveaux pièges tendus par l'industrie
de la nicotine j'espère que vous serez
nombreux à vous joindre à nous dans ce
combat et que le texte sera adopté à
l'unanimité ainsi cet hémicycle en
enverra un signal fort à nos collègues
sénateurs qui seront bientôt saisis de
ce texte et à nos collègues européens
qui luttent eux aussi contre ce fléo je
vous remercie je vous
remercie et donc maintenant la parole
est à Monsieur Michel laana rapporteur
de la commission des affaires
[Applaudissements]
sociales présid je bien monter parce que
moi j'ai des difficultés
après pour l la tête
sinon madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la présidente de la
commission des affaires sociales madame
la corapporteur mes chers collègues nous
voilà réunis enfin pour aborder la
proposition de loi transpartisane visant
à interdire les dispositifs
électroniques jetables ou à usage unique
d'ipuf enfin oui car l'urgence est bel
et bien là en ce moment même pendant que
nous débattons dans l' cycle et avant
que le vote final de cette proposition
de loi soit voté nous devons savoir que
plus d'une dizaine de peufs seront jeté
dans la nature et n'importe quel mineur
aura pu facilement s'en procurer et ce
malgré l'interdiction de vente au moins
de 18 ans face à ce constat accablant je
suis heureux de finaliser aujourd'hui la
première étape d'un processus législatif
et réglementaire qui débouchera sur une
interdiction pure et simple de la V de
la vente et et de la fabrication des
peufs en France à partir de septembre
j'espère au-delà de l'abération
environnementale mise en évidence par ma
corapporteur les peuf pose les risques
majeurs pour la santé publique et
d'abord pour nos jeunes l'Académie
nationale de médecine qualifie les peuvs
de pièges sournois pour les enfants et
les adolescents les derniers chiffres de
l'Alliance contre le tabac confirment
qu'il s'agit d'une véritable porte
d'entrée vers le tabagisme 15 % des
adolescents l'ont déjà utilisé et parmi
eux 47 % ont commencé leur initiation à
la nicotine à travers ce dispositif
ensuite par sa composition outre la
nicotine qui peut qui pe que peuvent
contenir les peufs elle compte parmi
leurs ingrédients du plastique et des
métaux lourds ça a été dit mais une fois
chauffé et leur vapeur inallé tout cela
ne fait pas bon ménage avec les les
poumons bien évidemment surtout pour les
enfants les peufs ne sont donc pas un
moyen de sevrage tabagique mais
représentent un danger environnemental
et sanitaire leur interdiction est
nécessaire et défendu par tous les
acteurs que ce soit les citoyens les
scientifiques les associations les
entreprises de vapotage et même les
buralistes c'est à noté ce travail est
ensuite ciblée notre proposition de loi
concerne uniquement les peuf après
adoption défin par le Parlement le
gouvernement devra notifier cette mesure
à la Commission européenne qui qui
disposera d'un délai de 6 mois pour
l'approuver ou la rejeter loin de
représenter une entrave à la
souveraineté du législateur il s'agit
d'une coordination évidente dès lors que
les liens que les biens pardon et les
services circulent librement dans le
marché
commun et de manière importante
l'exemple de la Belgique qui n'est pas
parvenu à interdire les peufs l'année
dernière est une une des raisons pour
laquelle nous focalisons cette PPL
strictement sur cet unique dispositif
afin de ne pas compromettre son
approbation par la Commission
européenne je sais néanmoins que cette
interdiction seule ne résoudra pas tous
les problèmes liés au tabagisme en
France c'est un DC que je salue vos
annonces récentes monsieur le ministre
dans le cadre du programme national de
lutte contre le tabac avec un double
objectif créer une génération
sans tabac d'c 2032 et accompagner les
fumeurs dans leur arrêt du tabac
monsieur le ministre la représentation
nationale se tient à vos côtés pour
atteindre ses
objectifs enfin il s'agit d'un travail
transpartisan je souhaite
particulièrement remercier ma
corapporteur Francesca Pasquini mais
également les députés Carl olive et
Bruno Studer avec qui nous avons
travaillé à bonne intelligence pour que
cette proposition de loi inscrite à
l'ordre de du jour de l'Assemblée
nationale soit vu ce soir je remercie
également les 166 autres députés de huit
bords politiques différents qui ont
cossigné cette proposition de loi ce
fléau touche tous nos
territoires je remercie enfin les
députés de la commission des affaires
sociales qui ont voté à l'unanimité en
faveur de cette proposition de loi ils
ont aussi abordé des problématiques
complémentaires je pense notamment au
sachet de nicotine au paquet neutre aux
espaces sans tabac aux apports des
écoles par exemple et donc je vous
invite collectivement à poursuivre cette
démarche transpartisane c'est le C de
nos concitoyens qui ont choisi cette
Assemblée nationale et c'est le vœux que
formulent les députés du groupe
Renaissance prêt à se mobiliser avec des
partenaires et parlementaires
responsables pour porter des sujets dans
l'intérêt de nos
concitoyens alors mes chers collègues je
vous invite massivement
à voté cette proposition de loi et à
poursuivre notre travail collectif de
lutte contre le tabagisme et les
produits nocifs conçu pardon par
l'industrie du tabac je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant monsieur Aurélien Rousseau
ministre de la santé et de la
prévention
madame la
présidente Madame la rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur mesdames et messieurs les
députés grâce à des années de politique
de santé publique volontariste l'usage
du tabac est aujourd'hui en nette baisse
chez les jeunes nous sommes passés de 25
% de prévalence à 16 %
c'est un combat qui nécessite de la
ténacité de l'engagement et qui
nécessite quelquefois aussi d'assumer de
porter des mesures pas forcément
populaires tous ceux qui sont sur ses
bans ce soir et les 166 signataires de
cette proposition de loi partagent cet
engagement vous le portez largement et
je voudrais vous dire que sans cette ce
travail qui conduit de fait à sortir de
la banalité un produit qui voudrait tout
faire pour être totalement anecdotique
voire ludique sans ce travail je crois
que le gouvernement n'aurait pas été en
mesure en tout cas moi je le dis ici
très sincèrement d'annoncer les mesures
que j'ai présenté la semaine dernière
dans le cadre du nouveau nouveau
programme national de lutte contre le
tabac
et c'est aussi pour moi une manière de
saluer des liens
entre le Parlement et le pouvoir
exécutif encore une fois c'est c'est
essentiel au-delà même du caractère
transpartisan et je salue évidemment le
travail remarquable de vos deux
corapporteurs Francesca pascini et
Michel
Lausana voilà
la ce ce programme national de lutte
contre le tabac que j'ai pu présenter la
semaine dernière vous le savez tout
pourrait se résumer mais dans ce terme
qui n'existe sans doute pas en français
par ailleurs que je j'ai indiqué tout à
l'heure de débanalisation de sortir de
la banalité du tabac alors évidemment
avec une intervention sur le prix avec
de la visibilité qui est donnée sur
cette augmentation du prix à nos
concitoyens la généralisation des
espaces sans tabac pour faire reculer le
tabac de l'espace public notamment de
l'espace public à proximité des plus
jeunes d'entre nous et évidemment la
accompagnement des fumeurs par divers
moyens et avec une attention
particulière accordée au plus précaes
pour apporter une aide adapté à chaque
profil de fumeur et je vois sur ces
bancs nombre de parlementaires qui par
ailleurs sont engagés par exemple je je
vois Carl olive à notre action en faveur
du sport santé qui est un complément
essentiel de la politique sur le tabac
tout cela me conforte dans le fait que
notre objectif d'une première génération
débarrassé du tabac dès 2032 est
réaliste et
atteignable c'est un objectif réaliste
et atteignable mais loin d'être acquis
et nous avions besoin j'en suis
convaincu de conjuguer nos ambitions
celles que vous portez aujourd'hui au
Parlement celle que le gouvernement a pu
présenter dans le plan national de lutte
contre le
tabagisme et cela est d'autant plus vrai
que les usages évoluent et que la
réponse des pouvoirs publics doit rester
adapté et agile pour relever les défis
qui se posent quand on dit défi qui se
pose on devrait plutôt dire les
innovations marketing que les grands
industriels ont toujours en tête pour
accompagner les plus jeunes de nos
concitoyens vers le
tabagisme il y a encore 10 ans la lutte
contre le tabagisme ciblé exclusivement
ou presque la cigarette aujourd'hui les
pratiques et les produits sont multiples
certains sont colorés et ludiques
ciblant clairement les jeunes à grand
renfort vous l'avez dit l'un et l'autre
de
marketing je parle bien sûr ici de
l'objet qui nous occupe ce soir la
cigarette électronique jetable ou à
usage unique que qui qui porte le joli
nom malheureusement de peuf par son prix
compétitif son emballage attractif ses
saveurs sucré et fruité la peuf ou le
peuf est est attractive et accessible
singulièrement auprès des jeunes
elle a gagné une popularité inquiétante
jusque chez les très jeunes malgré
l'interdiction de vant au mineur comme
le soulignait Michel Lausana chez les 13
16 ans un enfant sur 10 a déjà essayé la
peuf et et ce chiffre est sans cesse en
augmentation la peuf pourtant n'est ni
un moindre mal ni un outil de sevrage en
effet son taux de nicotine peut aller
jusqu'à 20 mg par milre
et il ouvre la voix une forte dépendance
elle crée aussi une accoutumance au
gestes de fumé tous ces éléments
contribuent à un effet passerelle
facilité vers le
tabagisme au-delà de l'aspect sanitaire
la cigarette électronique jetable et
particulièrement vous l'avez dit Madame
la rapporteur au regard de sa
composition de son caractère non
rechargeable fléo environnemental une
bombe à retardement en parfaite
contradiction notamment avec les Esprit
des lois que vous avez adopté notamment
sur
l'antigaspillage leur importation du
reste a déjà été interdite dans un
territoire de la République la
Nouvelle-Calédonie et en Europe la
Belgique l'Allemagne et
l'Irlande notamment s'achemine vers sa
proscription avec les difficultés que
Michel Lausana a pu rappeler ce sont
donc toutes ces raisons qui ont très
vite conduit tant l'Assemblée nationale
mais l'initiative vous en viient donc
que le gouvernement a proposé
l'interdiction de ces produits mesdames
et messieurs les députés la proposition
de loi que nous examinons ce soir avait
été déposé dès novembre
2022 nous avons eu l'occasion d'y
apporter notre soutien il y a quelques
mois et je suis très heureux aujourd'hui
de d'être ici à la tribune pour
réaffirmer l'engagement du gouvernement
derrière cette initiative votre
engagement mesdames et messieurs les
députés a donc été déter terminant et je
ne peux que le saluer saluer tout
particulièrement les premiers
signataires de cette proposition de loi
saluer l'esprit transpartisan qui nous
conduit ici aujourd'hui et qui a prévalu
en commission la semaine dernière je ne
suis pas surpris par ce cheminement
toutes et tous ici nous souhaitons aller
vers cet objectif d'une génération sans
tabac même si quelquefois nous savons ce
que ça peut nous imposer à nous-même
comme
contrainte toutes et tous nous
connaissons les risques pour la jeune
de ces dispositifs l'enjeu pour ce texte
est d'abord qu'il puisse produire ses
effets le plus rapidement possible j'ai
confiance dans le fait que les sénateurs
l'accueilleront avec autant
d'enthousiasme et de détermination que
vous l'avez ici
porté vous savez que la procédure de
notification à la Commission européenne
va rallonger le délai de quelques mois
mais je pense qu'il est indispensable
car nous avons face à nous des acteurs
qui sont extrêmement attentifs et s'il
le faut agressifs pour protéger leurs
produits et la sécurité juridique de
cette procédure est
essentielle bien sûr cette proposition
de loi doit s'inscrire dans un travail
plus large et de longue haline c'est un
des volets du nouveau pnlt qui vise à
anticiper les évolutions du marché pour
toujours mieux protéger nos concitoyens
c'est dans ce cadre que nous
continuerons de travailler à la di à la
diminution pardon de l'attractivité des
produits du tabac et du vapotage en
particulier le paquet neutre sera étendu
à tous les produits de tabac y compris
de vapotage et nous aurons l'occasion de
travailler cela avec vous dans la
perspective d'une nouvelle loi en ce
sens j'ai également pu annoncer que
j'engagerai très prochainement un
travail avec l'ensemble des parties
prenantes pour limiter les arômes
autorisés dans les produits de vapotage
voie détourné là aussi d'entrer dans le
tabac pour les jeunes et quand on voit
sur le site d'une des très grandes
marques du secteur le top 10 des
meilleures saveurs avec marshmallow
milcheck fraise ou pastèque givré on
mesure l'urgence de le faire nous
élaborons nous élaborerons également une
feuille de route pour renforcer la
surveillance des produits du tabac et de
vapotage et ainsi assurer une cohérence
à la réglementation dès qu'un nouveau
dispositif se présente je veux dire par
là
que je pense qu'il est indispensable que
nous soyons armés a priori par exemple
face au sachets de nicotine qui sont
encore un nouveaux modes de consommation
arrivé très récemment dans notre pays et
dont nous devons surveiller les
conséquences pour les plus jeunes
d'entre nous je sais pouvoir compter sur
tous les parlementaires engagés que je
ne pourrais ici citer et encore une fois
sur tous les bans tant cet en rassemble
largement à travers les groupes mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés Claude evvin
ministre de la Solidarité de la santé et
de la protection sociale le 25 juin 1990
avait dit dans cet
hémicycle que la lutte contre le
tabagisme a toujours eu dans nos
institutions une valeur symbolique sans
doute parce qu'il s'agit de légiférer
sur des comportements sur des activités
et des habitudes de vie qui conduisent à
la mort ou à la souffrance physique et
psychologique plus de 30 ans après ces
mots sont toujours d'actualité alors que
nous franchissons grâce à vous une
nouvelle étape pour que notre PS
réussisse dans cette lutte majeure
majeure parce que je le rappelle ce dont
il s'agit c'est de diminuer le terrible
chiffre de 200 morts par jour à cause du
tabac je vous
remercie je vous remercie donc
conformément à l'article 103 107-3 alé 2
du règlement avant de passer au vote sur
l'ensemble du texte adopté par la
commission j'appelle les amendements
numéro 1 et 2 déposés à afin de corriger
une erreur matérielle et donc nous les
amendements madame pascini si vous
voulez nous les oui nous les présenter
merci madame la Présidente pour les deux
amendements il s'agit de deux
amendements purement
rédactionnels je vous remercie alors
Monsieur le Ministre vos
avis
favorable alors sur les amendements vous
avez demandé un scrutin
public alors écoutez
oui oui mais voilà il y a des
explications de de vote de tous les
groupes donc donc on aura largement le
temps j'auraai largement le temps mes
chers collègues d'annoncer le scrutin
public alors je vais mettre s'il vous
plaît mais monsieur deogu je vous
remercie pour votre soutien ça me fait
très plaisir ça me touche beaucoup je
vais mettre au voie ces amendements
rédactionnels avec un double avis
favorable qui est
pour parfait très bien donc il est
adopté le numéro 2 même avis même vote
il est adopté également et donc dans les
explications de vote la première prise
de parole c'est Madame Rachel
[Applaudissements]
kéké
madame la Présidente chers collègues
tout d'abord je tiens à saluer le
travail des rapporteurs de cette
proposition de loi qui vise à interdire
les disposition les dispositifs
électroniques de vapotage à l'usage
unique consigné par 166 députés membres
de H groupes politiques de notre
assemblée cela démontre que notre notre
représentation nationale peut trouver
des compromis sur des questions majeures
de santé de santé pour la notre planète
et de santé pour nos jeunes pour
comprendre l'importance de cette
proposition de loi il faut comprendre
dans un premier temps l'importance et la
difficulté de la lutte contre le
tabagisme les chiffres de santé publque
France nous montre le chemin que nous
avons parcouru au fil des décennies face
à ce fléo il y a une cinquantaine
d'années la part de personnes consommant
du tabac quotidiennement se levait à 42
% et en 2022 elle passait enfin sous les
25 % de consommateurs cette baisse
significative est particulièrement
notable chez les jeunes de 17 ans la
consommation quotidienne de tabac est
passée d'une moyenne de 40 % en an 2000
et 15,6 % en
2022 mais alors qu'il y a une baisse
évidente de la consommation chez les
jeunes l'industrie du tabac lance des
nouveaux produits tels que les
cigarettes électroniques en 2010 et
surtout les cigarettes électronique à
l'usage unique appelé PEF en 2021 la PEF
a connu un succès
fugurant sa popularité croissante chez
les jeunes est liée à des stratégies de
marketing agressivees des prix
abordables à moins de 10 €, des
emballages qui donnent l'envie une
variété de saveur une forte promotion
par les influenceurs sur TikTok
Instagram ou snapchat tout cela a eu
l'effet de créer une nouvelle mode et
tendance les chiffres sont graves 13 %
de 13 à 16 ans ont déjà fait l'usage
d'après l'Alliance contre le tabac et 34
% des élèves de 3e d'après s
l'Observatoire des drogues et des
toxicomanes le problème est que c peuv
bien qu'ell ne contiennent pas de tabac
renfermant de la nicotine le risque
devient ainsi celui d'un passage de la
PEF vers la cigarette traditionnelle
c'est pourquoi je veux profiter de cette
tribune pour faire passer un message de
prévention c'est-à-dire de toutes celles
et ceux qui m'écoutent ne touchez jamais
à tout ce qu'il vient de l'industrie du
tas c'est un piège et je vais aussi dire
aux responsables politiques de montrer
l'exemple en ne vapontons pas au sein de
cette émicycle ou devant les caméras le
tabac est la première cause de mortalité
évitable en France avec 75000 décès par
an cela veut dire un décès sur 8 par an
à cause du tabac 200 morts par jour une
personne toutes les 7 minutes ces
chiffres ne sont pas justement des Satis
ce sont des vies perdues des familles
déchirées et des tragédies évitables en
interdissant les peuf on remet une
frontière entre les jeunes et
l'industrie du tabac cependant cette
polémique ne limite pas à la santé
individuelle elle a également de graves
conséquences sur la santé
environnementale les cigarettes
électroniques jetable avec leur
composition en plastique et leurs
batteries au lithium en ajoutant du
malheur au
malheur le temps où nous pouvions
ignorer l'impact de nos choix sur
l'environnement n'existe plus enfin vous
l'aurez compris du NON au tabac c'est
dit oui à la planète et oui à la santé
c'est pourquoi nous sommes favorables à
l'interdiction des cigarettes
électroniques à l'usage unique
merci je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Monsieur monsieur Stéphane
ver
oui merci beaucoup merci beaucoup madame
la Présidente mes chers collègues
monsieur monsieur le ministre le groupe
les républicains va naturellement voter
cette proposition de loi au début de
l'année 2023 j'avais posé une question
écrite à madame la Première ministre
l'invitant effectivement à prendre une
initiative pour mettre un terme à cette
situation anormale de consommation
excessive de
cigarettes jetable par voie électronique
effectivement les doubles raisons ont
été évoqué une raison
sanitaire tout d'abord monsieur le
ministre vous l'avez rappelé dans votre
propos c'est un véritable danger pour la
santé publique pour la santé publique
des jeunes et il fallait rapidement
prendre des mesures pour y remédier j'ai
un chiffre 47 % des jeunes ont entamé
leur initiation à la nicotine par ce
dispositif un sur de ça ne peut pas nous
laisser de marbre il faut impérativement
qu'on réagisse et la tendance
effectivement alimenté par des
stratégies marketing assez puissante par
un packaging attractif par des arômes et
si effectivement on y met pas un terme
de de façon nette on aura du mal à
lutter contre ce savoir-faire de la part
des des fabricants de ces cigarettes
électronique il fallait également mettre
un terme à une dérive écologique parce
que effectivement puisque c'est jetable
c'est un non sens écologique une fois
utilisé cette cigarette devient un
déchet non biodégradable qui menace à la
fois l'environnement et la biodiversité
donc face à ce double danger votre
proposition de loi mes chers collègues
était était de bon sens elle est
d'ailleurs consensuelle j'ai relevé dans
les auditions préparatoires aux travaux
commission tous les propos qui se
dégageaient qui invitaent effectivement
notre assemblée ce soir à être unanime
pour mettre un terme à cette situation
moi je voudrais dans mes quelques propos
donc vous confirmez effectivement que le
groupe les républicains sera au
rendez-vous de de ce vote je voudrais
quand même envoyer un message à l'égard
de nos buralistes parce qu'on a besoin
de nos buralistes partout dans les
territoires ils assurent parfois le
maillage territorial qui reste dans dans
dans nos villages et cette proposition
de loi ne l'aurait pas adressé en tout
cas c'est pas une marque contre eux
monsieur le ministre vous avez évoqué
dans vos propos j étis attentif comme
vos propos aujourd'hui dans lesvoges
j'ai été attentif effectivement à vos
propos sur la nécessité quand même de
modifier la réglementation sur tout ce
qui concerne la nicotine dans notre pays
il reste des des pas à faire pour
protéger la population par rapport à
tous les produits de nicotine il y a
actuellement une tendance effectivement
de gommer de la nicotine cette tendance
elle se développe c'est effectivement
très pernicieuse très dangereuse il
faudra pour protéger la santé de nos
enfants aller très vite et très loin sur
ce sujet-là voilà les quelques
observations que je voulais faire par
face à un problème sanitaire sur lequel
notre groupe sera en responsabilité et
votera cette proposition de loi je vous
remercie la parole est maintenant à
Monsieur Frédéric
gansski merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la Présidente de commission madame la
rapporteur monsieur le rapporteur chers
collègues alors que le programme
national de lutte contre le tabac que
vous avez présenté monsieur le ministre
la semaine passée inclu à cette
interdiction nous examinons aujourd'hui
une proposition de loi proposant
d'interdire les cigarettes électronique
dit jetable néfaste pour l'environnement
et la santé notamment celle des plus
jeunes contrairement au dispositifs de
vapotable rechargeable qui comme le
rappelait en septembre l'Office
parlementaire d'évaluation des choix
scientifiques et technologiques sont
principalement utilisés comme outil de
sevrage ces produits jetables à usage
unique présentés également comme une
aide au sevrage tabagique ne fut l'objet
d'aucune preuve scientifique affirmant
ce fait pire en raison d'un marketing
agressif ils sont en train de devenir un
enjeu majeur de santé publique au sein
des collèges et des lycées en effet nous
constatons que de plus en plus de jeunes
utilisent ces produits séduit par leur
packaging et leurs arômes sucrés ils
deviennent alors une porte d'entrée pour
les collégiens vers le tabagisme les
rendant addicte à la nicotine l'Académie
nationale de médecine nous alerte elle
constitue un piège particulièrement
sournoin pour les enfants et les
adolescents ainsi les conséquences de
ces peufes sont désastreuses sur le plan
sanitaire mais elles le sont également
sur le plan environnemental une
cigarette électronique jetable au regard
de sa composition et de son caractère
non rechargeable est un fléau
environnemental contraire à la loi
antig-aspillage pour une économie
circulaire et de toutes les initiatives
pour en finir avec l'usage unique
également il convient de noter la
provenance de ces équipements ils sont
pour la plus grande part fabriqué en
Chine si nous ne faisons rien il
remplacerait les systèmes de vapotage
rechargeable issus d'une filière du
vapotage normé par lafnor dès 2015 et
produit en France les dispositifs de
vapotage rechargeable français comme
produit une entreprise de ma
circonscription en Gironde à Cestas
répondent ainsi à ces exigences
environnementales et sanitaires au
contraire des dispositifs jetaes et il
nous faut donc ainsi préserver cette
industrie en conclusion je vous remercie
madame la rapporteur monsieur le
rapporteur pour la construction de cette
proposition de loi transpartisane que
j'ai Cigné considérant les effets nocifs
des cigarettes électroniques jeta non
seulement sur la santé mais également
sur notre environnement et sur notre
industrie le groupe démocrate votera
donc pour cette proposition de loi je
vous remercie je vous remercie la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Gérard
[Applaudissements]
leul merci madame la
Présidente madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la vice-présidente de
commission madame monsieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues nous
examinons ce soir la proposition de loi
transpartisane visant à interdire la
vente des peufs C si Garette
électronique à usage unique très
populaire chez les
adolescents un piège particulièrement
sournois pour les enfants et les
adolescents mais aussi un fléau
environnemental voilà comment nous
pourrions illustrer le débat de ce soir
c'est ce que je dénonçais déjà avec
notre ancienne collègue sénatrice
Catherine procassia dans la note 41 de
l'OPEX publié fin septembre 2023 et
intitulé nouveaux produits du tabac ou à
base de nicotine lever l'écran de fumée
et que vous avez eu madame monsieur
l'amabilité de citer dans votre rapport
rappelons d'ailleurs que le tabac est la
première cause de mortalité évitable en
France avec 75000 décès en 2015 soit à
peu près 13 % de ensemble des décès
étant à l'origine des cancers de
maladies cardio-vasculaires et de
pathologies respiratoires et bien qu'une
baisse de la consommation de tabac a été
observé en France au cours des dernières
années rappelons que 15,6 % des jeunes
de 17 ans et 3,7 % des élèves de 3e
déclarai fumé du tabac quotidiennement
prévalence particulièrement élevée en
comparaison des autres pays de l'OCDE et
marqué par de fortes inégalités sociales
l'addiction au tabac est principalement
nous le savons tous provoqué par la
nicotine qu'il contient et donc certains
fumeurs ont décidé ou tente d'arrêter de
de fumer certains d'ailleurs ont recours
à la cigarette électronique qui peut les
aider dans ces cas-là cependant depuis
leur invention plusieurs formes de
cigarettes électroniques sont apparues
sur le marché et en 2021 ces fameuses
cigarettes électroniques à usage unique
appelé
puuf on le sait cela a été dit à
plusieurs reprises elles sont vantées
pour leur praticité leur simplicité
d'utilisation à la fois par les
professionnels du secteur mais aussi par
les usagers ces dispositifs visent
volontairement une clientèle jeune
notamment au travers d'emballage et de
prix attractifs et malgré l'interdiction
de vente aux mineurs qui n'est pas
suffisamment respecté la PEF a vu ce son
marché très rapidement explosé en France
notamment grâce à des prix attractifs et
une large distribution magasins
spécialist vapot site internet certains
même appeler directement puuf bureau de
tabac magasins tels que wifi centre
accord bref on peut en trouver partout
la PUF c'est ce petit bâtonnet donc
légèrement plus large qu'un stylo au
packaging accrocheur vous l'avez dit
couleur fluo arôme sucré un marketing à
toute épreuve parlant de
différents arômes notamment les plus
plus addictif et puis nous avons aussi
un un marketing pour un produit qui peut
contenir jusqu'à 20 mg de nicotine et on
l'a rappelé tout à l'heure la nicotine
est justement ce qui provoque
l'addiction c'est bien ce qui pose la
difficulté majeure despuf aujourd'hui je
rappelle le prix nous savons que lespuf
globalement c'est entre 8 et 12 € alors
que pour 500 Bouffet contre à peu près
30 € pour un dispositif de de cigarettes
électronique rechargeable alors tout
cela nous inquiète parce que ça vise
clairement les adolescents et nous
savons que entre 2017 2022 l'utilisation
par les adolescents de la cigarette
électronique peuvent comprises à triplé
une étude récente de l'Alliance contre
le tabac et l'institut BVA publié le 14
novembre dernier affirme que 47 % des 13
16 ans ont commencé leur initiation à la
nicotine à travers ce dispositif soit
une hausse de 19 points par rapport à
l'an dernier nous sommes bien évidemment
sur des pratiques nouvelles et donc les
statistiques restent fragile mais ces
tendances doivent nous inquiéter et donc
outre son alarmante popularité chez les
adolescents nous devons bien évidemment
en raison de leur caractère jetable nous
interroger sur l'empreinte
environnementale on le sait on l'a dit
les cigarettes électroniques sont
aujourd'hui composé d'une batterie non
rechargeable qui contient à peu près
0,15 g de lithium et des métaux lourds
ces métaux et ce lithium que nous
retrouvons partout puisque globalement
nous n'avons pas mise en place de
système de traitement de retraitement et
de recyclage de l'ensemble de ces
cigarettes électroniques et donc dans la
dans la pratique les cigarettes
électroniques à usage unique sont des
déchets complexes mal collectés mal
recyclés que l'on retrouve dans les sol
les nappes fratiques et les et les
océans je salue donc l'initiative prise
par nos collègues initiative à la quel
d'ailleurs j'ai souscrit ainsi que
plusieurs collègues de mon groupe et le
groupe socialiste et apparenté votera
favorablement cette interdicction des
peuf je vous remercie je vous remercie
la parole est maintenant à Monsieur Paul
Christophe alors attendez que votre
micro fonctionne allez-y merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la Présidente de la commion affaires
sociales madame monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et Messieurs chers collègues
sans surprise le groupe horizon et
apparenté soutiendra bien évidemment
cette proposition de loi car oui nous
devons interdire les dispositifs
électroniques de vapotage à usage unique
car derrière l'emballage coloré et les
goûs attractifs de ces puufs se cache la
première cause de mortalité en France
vous l'avez rappelé monsieur le ministre
75000 décès par an quasiment 200 décès
par jour j'ai bien dit le tabagisme sans
contrôle de l'âge des acheteurs avec un
marketing agressif à destination de nos
jeunes et bien moins cher que les
cigarettes dites classiques les peufs
sont un véritable une véritable bombe à
retardement
pour la santé de nos concitoyens et un
frein à notre lutte collective contre le
tabagisme et toutes les formes
d'addiction pour prendre un exemple
concret en 2022 13 % des adolescents de
13 à 16 ans les ont déjà testé et dans
28 % des cas il s'agissait de la
première consommation de nicotine de
leur vie ce chiffre prouve ainsi que les
peufs sont des produits néfastes dit
d'appel qui mène à l'addiction à la
nicotine et au tabac j'espère donc que
nous mettrons aujourd'hui un terme à ce
fléau sanitaire en suivant l'exemple de
l'Allemagne de la Belgique ou encore de
l'Irlande qui ont déjà voté pour
l'interdiction de ces produits du fait
de leurs conséquences néfastes pour la
santé comme pour l'environnement car oui
ces produits constituent une aberration
écologique en totale contradiction
finalement avec les objectifs de
réduction des déchets de la France afin
d'aller plus loin pour la prévention
notamment pour les plus jeunes et la
régulation des nouveaux produits du
tabac le groupe horizon avait déposé en
commission des amendements en suiv
l'esprit des lois contre le tabac teles
que le paquet neutre pour les produits
du vapotage l'interdiction des arômes ou
encore des sachets de nicotine nous
sommes heureux de constater que ces
mesures font l'objet d'une attention
toute particulière monsieur le ministre
dans le cadre du plan national annoncé
dernièrement par vous-même comme la
mesure visant à limiter les arôes
autorisés pour dans les produits de
vapotage vous nous l'avez rappelé ces
nouveaux produits appelaient donc notre
responsabilité collective et nous avons
été à la hauteur de l'enjeu puisque
cette loi vous l'avez rappelé cher
rapporteur est transpartisane elle a
recueilli la signature de H groupes et
de bon nombre d'entre nous et elle a été
voté rappelons-le à l'unanimité en
commission des affaires sociales donc je
remercie les corrapporteurs
particulièrement investis sur le sujet
nous souhaitons réussir le défi d'une
génération sans tabac dès 2032 le groupe
horizon et apparaté votera en faveur de
ce texte je vous remercie la parole est
maintenant à Madame Julie
lernous
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre madame la rapporteur monsieur
le rapporteur mes chers collègues les
écologistes voteront résolument pour
cette proposition de loi qui vise à
interdire les dispositif électronique de
vapotage à usage unique nous nous
félicitons de l'inscription à l'ordre du
jour de ce texte transpartisan à
l'initiative des écologistes je salue le
travail notamment de ma collègue
Francesca Pasquini qui a mené en tant
que rapporteur pour mettre ce sujet de
santé publique primordial à l'ordre du
jour et l'engagement qui a été le sien
tout au long de ce travail au cours
duquel elle a parvenu à réunir plus de
150 signatures dans H groupes politiques
différents il est impossible en effet
d'avoir échapper au phénomène peuf ces
cigarettes électroniques jetables et
colorées qui ont envahi tous nos tabacs
revendeurs parfois même la grande
distribution elles se sont d'abord
imissé dans le marché américain et elles
ont ensuite infiltré le mar chez
français depuis 2 ans sans que nous ne
réagissions goût sucré couleur criarde
facilité d'usage ces produits sont
marquetés comme des bonbons en ciblant
clairement les plus jeunes ils sont
prêts à l'emploi facilitant la création
de nouvelles addictions 15 % des 13 16
ans ont déjà tiré une bouffée d'une peuf
pour la moitié d'entre eux il s'agissait
de la première fois qu'il consommaient
de la nicotine et en une bouffée une
peuf si vous me permettez cet anglicisme
voilà les dépendances à vie qui se secré
comment peut-on laisser des objets avec
des conséquences graves pour la santé
entre les mains d'enfants et
d'adolescents c'est un impératif éthique
aujourd'hui d'aboutir à une interdiction
pure et simple de ces dispositifs nous
ne pouvons pas laisser des marques
s'enrichir sur le dos des jeunes
générations en faisant naître des
dépendances graves car les peufs ne sont
pas simplement une menace alarmante pour
la santé de toutes et tous elles sont
aussi une aberration d'un point de vue
environnemental les peufs reproduisent
un modèle de consommation rapide basé
sur le jetable qui n'est pas compatible
avec les objectifs écologiques que l'on
considère les peufs sous l'angle des
déchets ou des ressources elles sont une
absurdité 3 ans après l'adoption de la
loi àc alors que tout le monde convient
de l'inepsie d'avoir des dispositifs à
usage unique il est tout simplement
aberérrant de laisser ces peufs classés
parmi les déchets d'équipement
électrique et électronique se soustraire
à la réglementation sur le recyclage des
déchets les peufs ne sont pas recyclable
et finissent jeter n'importe où et
n'importe comment et pourtant ell
présentent un risque non négligeable
d'incendie lié à leur batterie
facilement inflammable c'est sans parler
que du fait que les peufs nécessitent
également du lithium ressource précieuse
notamment dans la fabrication de
batteries pour véhicules électriques or
il faut un minimum de cohérence nous ne
pouvons pas simultanément nous inquiéter
du manque de lithium pour produire des
véhicules électriques puis fermer les
yeux quant à la présence de dans lespuf
si vous pensez que c'est marginal
laissez-moi vous citer un chiffre qui
j'espère vous fera réfléchir rien qu'en
2022 la quantité de lithium nécessaire
pour produire les peufs aurait pu
permettre la fabrication de 11000
batteries de véhicules électriques suite
aux annonce décevante du gouvernement
autour du plan antittabac la semaine
dernière cette proposition de loi
présente un réel intérêt pour interdire
de toute urgence ces dispositifs qui
vont à contesens de la lutte contre le
tabagisme contre les addictions et qui
présente un danger réel pour la santé
publique et environnementale pour toutes
ces raisons nous soutiendrons cette
proposition de loi et nous espérons
sincèrement que l'assemblée votera
aujourd'hui pour l'interdiction des
peufs je vous remercie je vous remercie
alors je vous indique que sur le vote de
cette PPL je suis saisie par le groupe
Renaissance et le groupe écologiste
d'une demande de scrutin public qui est
annoncée dans notre enceinte la parole
est maintenant à Monsieur Yannick
Mony merci madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la teur depuis leur
apparition en France en 2021 les
dispositifs électroniques de vapotage à
usage unique appelés couramment les PFS
ont suscité de nombreuses réprobations
de la part de l'Observatoire français
des drogues et des tendances addictives
du Comité national contre le tabagisme
de l'Alliance contre le tabac ou encore
de l'Académie nationale de médecine une
tribune signée d'une vingtaine de
médecins tabacologues et militants
écologistes écologique pardon paru dans
Le Monde le 30 avril dernier dénoncer
ainsi ce fléau environnemental et
sanitaire que représentent ces
cigarettes électroniques à usage unique
spécifiquement élaboré pour être
attirante pour les adolescents avec un
emballage attractif des saveurs sucrés
et fruités et un prix relativement
faible disponible chez les buralistes
mais également une en grande
distribution et sur Internet les peufs
ont rapidement séduit un public jeune et
insuffisamment conscient de ses effets
de dépendance tant à la nicotine qu'à la
gestuelle du fumeur il a été ainsi
démontré que les peufs constituent une
porte d'entrée vers le vapotage durable
et le tabac du point de vue
environnemental la situation n'est pas
meilleure que du point de vue de la
santé publique plastique lithium métau
lourd ça a été dit tout à l'heure les
composants non biodégradables et non
recyclables des vapoteuses jetables ont
un impact certain sur l'environnement et
particulièrement au niveau de la
pollution de l'eau et des sols que les
députés décident aujourd'hui de réagir à
hauteur des alertes lancées par les
différentes études en santé publique et
en matière environnementale est une
bonne chose les députés communistes
ultramarins du groupe GDR vteront cette
PPL toutefois cette interdiction des
peufs que nous nous apprêtons à voter ne
doit pas nous conduire à délaisser un
certain nombre d'autres difficultés
celle des réseaux sociaux qui
contribuent très largement à la
promotion de ce type de dispositif
auprès des jeunes le fait aussi que ces
dispositifs de cigarettes électroniquees
jeta ou les sachets de nicotine par
ailleurs évoqué en commission sont au
cœur de la stratégie des industrielles
du secteur du tabac Philippe Maurice
aspire ainsi à réaliser 50 % de son
chiffre d'affaires au moyen de produits
sans fumer en 2025 ces dispositifs
constituent un moyen de contrer la
baisse des ventes de cigarettes
traditionnelles dans de nombreux pays
occidentaux mais c'est aussi un levier
de promotion pour le tabac lui-même
c'est également le cas de British
américain tobacco qui aurait dépensé
plus d'un milliard d'euros pour
promouvoir ses produits sans tabac sur
les réseaux sociaux selon une enquête du
Guardian publié en 2021 demeure aussi la
question cruciale d'une politique de la
prévention des addictions et de
l'accompagnement des personnes souffrant
d'addiction qu'il s'agisse de celle au
tabac à l'alcool au jeux en ligne ou
plus largement aux écrans monsieur le
ministre c'est une une réflexion que
nous aurions souhaité partager plus
amplement dans le cadre du PLFSS mais
comme chacun sait ce n'est plus chose
permise néanmoins nous pensons que si le
législateur doit intervenir pour
interdire des dispositifs dont le danger
est avéré il doit également pouvoir
intervenir pour mieux encadrer les
logiques marchandes peu soucieuses de la
santé publique et de l'environnement
ainsi que pour améliorer la prévention
et la réparation je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à Monsieur Paul André
Colombani madame la Présidente Monsieur
le Ministre madame la Présidente de
commission madames et Messieurs les
rapporteurs chers collègues notre groupe
soutient l'interdiction des dispositifs
électroniques de vapotage à usage unique
convaincu que le principe de précaution
doit s'appliquer nous avons conscience
que le rapport bénéfice risque est
aujourd'hui encore mal connu les études
à notre disposition ne nous permettent
pas de conclure à l'existence d'une for
plus forte toxicité de ces prod
dispositifs comparativement à la
cigarette ou d'autres produits du
tabac mais elle ne nous permet pas non
plus de conclure à une absence d'effets
négatifs sur la santé surtout les études
affirment que les peufs ne permettent
pas de se severer dire qu'elles sont une
alternative moins nocive au tabac ne
suffit pas à en faire un produit de
substitution plus encore elles ne
doivent pas être un outil de notre
politique de lutte contre le tabagisme
comme certains pays l'ont fait pire et
c'est le principal argument qui doit
motiver leur interdiction elles peuvent
avoir un effet d'entraînement à tel
point que l'Alliance contre le tabac
qualifie les peufs de prédateur de la
jeunesse le marketing est clairement
ciblé sur les jeunes y compris les
mineurs en dépit de leur interdiction
avec des produits colorés des goûts
attractifs voire enfantins le tout porté
par des messages de moindre toxicité
voire de non toxicité qui peut être
incitatif et donc contreproductif pour
la lutte globale contre le
tabagisme le dernier argument en faveur
de l'interdiction de l'impact le dernier
argument en faveur de l'interdiction est
l'impact écologique avéré des produits à
usage unique et des composants
assurément toxique pour l'environnement
notre groupe soutiendra donc cette
proposition de loi avec un regret de ne
pas aller de ne pas avoir pu aller
au-delà de la seule interdiction des
peufs nous avions proposé en commission
de mettre en œuvre les recommandations
de l'Office Parlementaire comme comme
mise en place des comme la mise en place
d'emballage neutre pour les produits de
vapotage ou encore l'interdiction des
arômes dit piège à enfant pour les
cigarettes électronique monsieur le
ministre nous prenons bonne note de
votre engagement à le faire mais à quel
éch
nous avions également proposé
d'améliorer l'information notamment à
destination des plus jeunes il faut
faire cesser l'idée que ces dispositifs
de vapotage seraient non nocif pour la
santé sous prétexte qui contiennent peu
ou pas de nicotine nous regrettons que
cette proposition n'est pas été retenu
d'une manière générale le plan antit
tabac pr présenté la semaine dernière
doit intégrer ses aspects et mieux
anticiper l'avènement de nouveaux
produits des nouveaux produits du tabac
comme le tabac chauffé le tabac mâché ou
à prisé
et les sachets de nicotine nous devons
renforcer notre action à destination des
fumeurs pour les aider à arrêter et
mieux les accompagner avec une donnée
que nous avons devons toujours avoir
tous en tête le tabagisme est la
première cause de mortalité évitable en
France je vous
remercie je vous remercie la parole est
à monsieur Carl
olive
présidente madame la Présidente Monsieur
le le ministre madame la rapporteur
monsieur le rapporteur mes chers
collègues après un an de travail nous
pouvons dire enfin enfin cette
proposition de loi transpartisane visant
à interdire les dispositif de vapotage à
usage unique ou peuf sera voté et adopté
il s'agit d'une avancée essentielle qui
sera prise en exemple chez nos voisins
européens tant le fléau des cigarettes
électroniques jetaes chez les
adolescents et pour l'environnement est
préoccupant préoccupant car ces peufs
sont une nouvelle porte d'entrée dans la
dépendance à la nicotine et au produits
du tabac préoccupant car le marketing
les goûts Malabar carambar frais Tagada
pastèque givré les couleurs des paquets
les publicités illégales sur les réseaux
sociaux autour de ces peeuves visent
principalement les adolescents
préoccupant car nous voyons des
collégiens et parfois des primaires y
succomber et en vapotter devant les
grilles des ét établissement comme je
l'ai vu à poissie préoccupant car ces
peufs contiennent des taux de nicotine
beaucoup trop importants pour des
cerveaux encore en formation préoccupant
car elles contiennent des produits
chimiques du lithium et du plastique que
nous ne pouvons pas recycler préoccupant
car plus d'un million de peufs sont
jetés chaque semaine sans que nous ne
puissions les recycler préoccupant enfin
car nous retrouvons ces peuves dans la
nature dans toutes nos circonscriptions
sur nos plages dans nos parcs dans nos
rivière au cours de ces derniers mois
une véritable prise de conscience s'est
opérée parmi l'ensemble des acteurs
français les acteurs du vapotage les
buralistes les associations
environnementales les médecins le
gouvernement tous ont exprimé
publiquement ou leur des audition leur
mobilisation contre ces dispositifs oui
il y a un soutien unanime à cette
proposition de loi mes chers collègues
ces peuves deviennent aujourd'hui une
nouvelle porte d'entrée vers l'industrie
du tabac cette ind de la dépendance
cette industrie de la mort nous ne le
rappellerons jamais assez mais le tabac
se sont chaque année dans notre pays
75000 morts ce sont 200 morts par jour
ces chiffres ne sont pas simplement des
statistiques ce sont des prénoms des
vies des familles brisées et
endeuillé permettez-moi d'évoquer
brièvement dans cet hémicycle l'hispoir
d'une de ces victimes Philippe fumeur
depuis son adolescence une taf une cl un
paquet une cartouche il est devenu
addicte à la nicotine addicte aux
différents poisons contenus dans ses
cigarettes qu'il consommait tous les
jours depuis tant d'années Philippe est
mort lui aussi trop tôt trop jeune il
avait 46 ans Philippe était mon frère
aîné j'ai été témoin personnellement des
ravages de cette industrie sur nos vies
voilà pourquoi je la combat de toutes
mes forces mes chers collègues de
nombreuses adolescents succombent
aujourd'hui à cette industrie que ce
soit par la arê traditionnelle ou par
les nouveaux produits tels que les peufs
je le rappelle 15 % des ados ont déjà
consommé des peufs et parmi eux 47 % ont
consommé leur initiation à la nicotine
avec elle les sachets de nicotine et les
billes de nicotine qui peuvent Infiné
conduire au produits du tabac un
trempelin nocif avant une descente
inéluctable aux enfers cette proposition
de loi transpartisane mes chers collègu
constituons donc un premier pas dans le
prolongement du plan contre le tabac
présenté la semaine dernière par
monsieur le ministre Aurélien Rousseau
que je salue mais cette action
parlementaire devra être suivie par
d'autres textes nous devons réfléchir
collectivement aux autres nouveaux
produits de la nicotine comme les
sachets nicotine ou les billes de
nicotine comme les sachets à la vente en
ligne et au contrôle de l'âge pour
réussir l'objectif d'une génération sans
tabac ne soyons ni DUP ni en retard de
de ce qui se joue sous nos yeux les
règles européennes nous obligent
aujourd'hui à avancer progressivement
mais je ne doute pas du de cette
première avancée pour poursuivre de
manière transpartisane sur ces autres
produits je ne doute pas du soutien du
gouvernement aux futurs travaux
parlementaire pour avancer ensemble vers
cet objectif d'une génération sans tabac
avant le vote de cette proposition de
loi que j'espère unanime je tenais à
remercier nos deux rapporteurs Francesca
paskini et Michel Lausana mais également
notre collègue Bruno Studer pour les
échanges et la qualité des travaux que
nous avons menés depuis plusieurs mois
Mo merci également pour la rigueur et
l'excellence avec lesquel l'ensemble des
collègues parlementaires ont conduit
cette proposition de loi jusqu'au vote
de ce soir car nous n'aurons aucune
mensuétude pour cette industrie
évidemment du Tabas et de la dépendance
cette proposition de loi bénéficiera
donc du soutien unanime du groupe
Renaissance merci je vous remercie la
parole est maintenant Monsieur Serge
muler merci madame la
Présidente Monsieur le Ministre madame
la Présidente de la Commission monsieur
le rapporteur au prix attractif
d'environ 8 € l'unité les peufs sont des
mini cigarettes électroniques et
jetables et non rechargeables aux arômes
sucrés ou fruités fraises bananes goût
bonbons j'en pass et des meilleurs et
aux emballages coloré popularisé en
France via les réseaux sociaux tels que
TikTok ou Instagram elles sont à la mode
chez les adolescents en 2022 l'Alliance
contre le tabac a indiqué que 13 % des
adolescents âgés de 13 à 16 ans avaient
déjà utilisé une peuf et que 28 %
d'entre
eux correspondaient à la première
consommation de nicotine or vapoté avec
des peufs est mauvais pour la santé et
l'environnement la plupart des peufs
contiennent de la nicotine selon le taux
de nicotine elle contient une peuf peut
en moyenne équivaut à 40 cigarettes les
jeunes sont particulièrement vulnérables
à la nicotine en raison de ses effets
sur le développement de leur cerveau
l'accoutumeance à la nicotine est par
ailleurs la porte d'entrée vers le
tabagisme les peufs ont une empreinte
environnementale importante les
consignes de tri qui prévoit que les
peufs soi jeté à la déchetterie ou dans
les boîtes pour pil usagé ou déchets
électroniques sont peu ou prou
respectés plusieurs pays ont interdit ou
envisagent d'interdire la
commercialisation des peufs la
Nouvelle-Zélande l'Allemagne la Belgique
le Royaume-Uni et cetera
ou en rinstreint les arômes contenus
dans ce
ilquide par exemple l'Islande les
Pays-Bas le Danemark le rassemblement
national se félicite de l'adoption à
l'unanimité en en commission de
l'interdiction des peup dans notre pays
nous saluons cette décision importante
pour la santé publique de nos enfants et
pour la protection de
l'environnement ainsi le rassemblement
national votera donc pour ce texte dans
une logique volontaire et responsable je
vous
remerci je vous remercie donc je vais
mettre au voie la proposition de
loi nous allons procéder au scrutin
merci gagnez vos places le scrutin est
ouvert le scrutin est
[Musique]
clos alors votant 108 exprimé 104
majorité 53 pour 104 contre 0
l'Assemblée nationale a
adopté alors monsieur le rapporteur vous
avez la
parole merci madame la Présidente avant
de vous remercier tous je voudrais
amener quelques réponses monsieur viri
vous avez soulevé un problème important
qui est celui des buralistes je voulais
vous dire que dans le nouveau plan en
tire de lutte contre le tabac c'est un
des axes importants que l'accompagnement
des buralistes et c'est très important
vous avez raison nous avions d'ailleurs
déjà je crois que c'était avec Darmanin
monsieur Darmanin quand il était
ministre du Budget que nous avions déjà
ébaucher cette reconversion vers le
multiservice et en tout cas c'est un
accompagnement qui est nécessaire
ensuite à Monsieur Colombani je voulais
lui dire que c'est avec un crève-cœur
que nous avons refusé les amendements
qui étaient portés euh dans la dans la
commission parce que ils étaient tous
euh très bienvenus comme d'ailleurs ceux
de du groupe horizon que dont as parlé
monsieur Christophe mais si nous avons
fait cela je l'ai déjà dit c'est pour ne
pas fragiliser cette proposition de loi
qui va être notifié à la Commission
européenne et on veut que cette loi soit
effective le plus rapidement possible ce
qui fait qu'il faut vraiment nous nous
cantonner au peuf voilà je ne serai pas
plus loin en tout cas je vous remercie
tous et à tous aussi qui ont permis
pardon l'adoption de cette loi
transpartisane je vous remercie madame
la rapporteur vous avez la parole merci
madame la Présidente merci chers
collègues pour l'adoption à l'unanimité
de cette proposition de loi je tenais
également à remercier Monsieur le
Ministre mon collègue Michel lozana mais
également mes collègues Bruno studur et
Carl olive qui ont contribué aussi au
succès de cette proposition de loi je
tenais également à remercier le groupe
écologiste de m'avoir soutenu tous mes
collègues de laanupes l'administrateur
de la commission des affaires sociales
monsieur rinert et puis tous les
collaborateurs qui ont participé et
travaillé vraiment beaucoup sur ce texte
merci à
tous je vous remercie la séance est
suspendue pour 2 minutes